[Music]
has the pandemic revealed the true
nature of the west relationship with
china the historian neil ferguson argues
in this week's cover article that
while the perception of china is worse
than it has been in many recent decades
the west also seems to be taking from
the beijing playbook
it's one of the ideas that he explores
in his new book doom the politics of
catastrophe
neil ferguson joins me now from
stanford's university's hoover
institution
neil welcome to spectator tv let's start
by talking about this concept you
mentioned of osmosis in war
what does that mean well this is an idea
that
i i came across when i was reading
norman mailers
the naked and the dead researching a
book about world war
ii years ago now the book was the war of
the world
and the idea is that you kind of become
like your
enemy uh even if you win that that's the
notion
and it was an idea that came up in world
war ii of course because
the democracies had to create enormous
systems of planning and control
to win world war ii and then in the cold
war
a recurrent theme of of commentary from
conservatives and
from the left as well think of george
orwell
was that there was a kind of convergence
happening and the united states and its
allies were becoming more and more like
the soviet union and its allies this was
an idea john
kenneth galbraith wrote up in the 1960s
so this idea of the osmosis of war that
you become like your enemy i think is
relevant today
because there's a danger that we could
become
uh are becoming uh more and more like
our principal strategic rival the
people's republic of china
and what are the ways do you think that
this is manifesting in
well there are a bunch for example joe
biden on the phone to
boris johnson saying hey we need to have
our own
one belt one road uh initiative
uh there's the way that last year when
uh it was clear that covert 19 was
spreading uh
more or less uncontrolled through the uk
and the us we
we copy much that the chinese did the
idea of
of lockdowns uh was in many ways based
on what china did after around january
uh the 23rd last year when they
basically
froze uh the the chinese
economy and and chinese society
i i saw an interview the other day uh
with the other neil ferguson i'm not
him the guy at imperial college who
spells his name a bit differently
in which he said well we we didn't know
if we could do lockdowns
and then the chinese showed us as that
it could happen and then we
we discovered we could do it even though
we're not a communist state
so that's another example and i i could
go on i think central bank digital
currency is a good example
the chinese have pioneered this idea and
suddenly everybody's saying
where's the fed's central bank digital
currency where's the bank of england and
the bank of england has set up a task
force to explore
this idea so across the board i think
we're seeing the osmosis of of cold war
in
in
cold war too and what's particularly
fascinating about that neil ferguson's
interviews he said
we then we realized we could get away
with it and i remember writing a piece
in february last year about china's we
had locked down thinking this could
never happen
in the uk but then of course it happened
all across the west
when it comes to this security versus
liberty
tension do you think that a lot of the
west's are leaning towards security in
the last year especially on covet
it's because of this sort of state of
emergency that we've been in this global
pandemic scaring people
into this and so after the threat is
over maybe we'll be less like china in
that way
well in do i try to argue that it wasn't
a straightforward choice between
letting the virus rip and getting to
herd immunity
as it were naturally and locking
everything down
that that was the wrong choice uh to
think about
that there was a choice it existed in in
january which was to do what the
taiwanese did and the south koreans did
uh they didn't lock down in fact taiwan
has never had a lockdown
what they did was to ramp up testing
because it was possible to
to test for the new virus very early on
once it had been
uh genetically sequenced at the same
time
to create a system of contact tracing
and then to
make be able to isolate or quarantine
people who are suspected of being ill
they did that very quickly and as a
result hardly anybody in taiwan has died
of
of covert 19 i think the grand total is
11
to date despite the fact that they're
right next door
to the people's republic so i think one
obvious question for public health
officials in the west is
why didn't you do that why did you sit
around
january february and into mid-march
really not doing very much at all
and then in mid-march you read neil
ferguson's report panicked at the
thought that there were going to be
2.2 million deaths in the u.s half a
million in the uk
and and then you shut everything down in
this very indiscriminate way
that had lots of unintended consequences
the full scale of which i don't think we
we understand even even today so i i
think one has to realize that there were
other
options but we decided and i think it
was a wrong decision to copy
the people's republic of china rather
than to copy the republic of china
taiwan if we'd copied the taiwanese
playbook
we would have had i'm absolutely sure
significantly less
excess mortality and much much less
economic disruption
now you could say contact tracing apps
on our phones that sounds like
that sounds like a terrible threat to
civil liberties but i can assure you
it's
a it's a smaller threat than being under
house arrest
as a great many of us were for a large
part of
of last year i mean if if if it's civil
liberty to be
to be shut in your own home under a
shelter-in-place order
then as ian hislock once said i'm a
banana
although taiwan does shut down its
borders pretty early on because it was
suspicious of the people's republic of
china i mean do you think that's
an acceptable trade-off to make
throughout history and
times of plague there have been
restrictions on travel
and one of the stranger things about
2020 was
how slow the us and the uk were
to realize that uh it was clearly
not wrong for donald trump to argue back
in january that there should be a travel
ban that there should be limits
on passengers coming into the us from
china but
he came up with the idea a couple of
weeks too late for it really to make
much
impact and of course there were
exceptions so u.s citizens and green
card holders
were exempt the same is true by the way
today uh indians
uh can't travel freely to the united
states
but indians with green cards can and u.s
citizens who've been in india can
and that isn't going to stop the indian
variant from arriving in the united
states so yeah i mean the taiwanese
response
which of course at its counterparts in
australia and new zealand and other
countries
was the right one when there's a new
pathogen running a mark in a country
stop people coming from that country
regardless of what passport or visa they
have
that's that's the kind of knowledge that
they already had about plagues back in
the middle ages
and let's talk about the cold war um you
you mentioned your book that cold war ii
has
already started and and you argue that
china
is the aggressor to this from from what
i what i've been talking to people with
in china and
whether it's academics or people they
actually think that it's the west who
are itching to start a cold war too what
do you say to those people
well as a visiting professor at singhua
i have quite a few
chinese academic friends and and friends
in
the world of chinese policy i've been
struck by how readily
they've accepted the cold war ii analogy
uh there's not a lot of pushback when
you when you make
this kind of argument uh of course as in
the first cold war
the communist side always argues that
it was the west that started it but but
this is a pretty unconvincing
argument i think when you look back on
xi jinping's track record since
he came to power in china because really
from that moment on china's been far
more
explicit in its geopolitical and
technological
ambitions and as i try and show in the
book
discussions within the chinese
intelligentsia
are really quite explicit about the
objective of displacing
the united states as the dominant world
empire
with the people's republic of china when
you think about the way in which
china has increased its national
security expenditures its capabilities
uh its militarization of the south china
sea its increasing assertiveness towards
uh other asian countries think of the
way it's been beaten
it's been beating up on australia
recently it's kind of hard to claim that
that cold war ii started uh in
washington as opposed to
to beijing and i i think we're rather in
the u.s in the same situation that we
were in at the beginning of
of cold war one and in the 1940s when
george orwell and winston churchill said
we're in a cold war most americans were
very slow to
accept that there was a sort of denial
that that persisted
almost until the outbreak of the korean
war in 1950
and i think we're still at that stage
now in cold war too a lot of
intellectuals
at stanford or harvard would say no no
this isn't cold war ii that's the wrong
analogy
uh we should be striving for
coopertition with china which is a
hideous word but i think this is the
stage of denial that you typically find
in the west at the
beginning of a cold war well i guess
part of their worries is probably that
you know in a cold war as we saw in in
the 60s
you know we had people on both sides
kind of characterizing
each other as these one-sided
one-dimensional
players and actors and in many ways
china is not quite like the ussr it's
not
ideologically driven in the same way
that the ussr was it seems
much more keen on lining its pockets uh
wherever possible
um so do you think that the cold war
mentality you know
sorry the cold war parallel has
limitations in how to understand china
as the new
uh strategic threat well i think
it's true to say that in cold war one
there was a great deal of
uh of caricaturing of the other side but
that wasn't
by any means the worst thing about one
one
not to mention the nuclear brinkmanship
and the proxy wars that cost
enormous numbers of lives from southeast
asia to
to central america and sub-saharan
africa
i think you can have a cold war without
those things certainly without the
nuclear brinkmanship and the proxy wars
uh but i think it's almost inevitable
that in the way
things are currently going that the
rhetoric on both sides
is becoming more and more hostile
and attitudes towards the chinese
government are becoming more and more
negative
in in the western world the pew group
showed that with some remarkable survey
data
back in october but my argument for cold
war ii
is not uh an argument against uh
a happy and cordial relationship i just
don't think a happy and cordial
relationship is possible
with this chinese government pursuing
these strategic goals
the thing we're trying to avoid is hot
war three i mean we do not want the us
and china to end up
in a shooting war whether it's over
taiwan uh or the south china sea or some
other
issue and the great point of cold war
one was to avoid
world war three it was to avoid a
nuclear exchange between the united
states and the soviet union and it did
that
contained the soviets expansion pretty
peacefully in the sense that there
wasn't a
head-to-head war over uh europe uh
and and i think that's really the point
of cold war that you'd rather have a
cold war than a hot war and i think
that's
that's why cold wars happen and why
ultimately they're preferable
to making a series of miscalculations
which i think we're still well capable
of doing
uh that produce world war three it's not
difficult to imagine
a major escalation happening over an
issue like taiwan
and if you talk to people of the us
military i think of my
old friend jim stavridis who's just
published a novel about this
the scenarios are pretty terrifying
because the u.s china war would very
quickly escalate
from the taiwan strait to bombing of uh
mainland targets and then potentially to
nuclear exchanges that's that's how
steve redis imagines it in his novel so
as i've been arguing now for more than
two years that you'd rather have
cold war ii than world war three okay so
you say that we should compete with
china but not copy it so what does that
competition look like
i think it looks like what we currently
see
in the realm of vaccines uh where the
west
is able to take advantage of its
technological edge and the greater
competition
that there is when it comes to vaccine
development in the western world i mean
the competition between companies
biotech companies like moderna
uh and beyond tech is one of the reasons
we ended up with mrna
uh vaccines uh i think it looks like
that in artificial intelligence
one of the striking things about ai is
that the us still has a
qualitative lead partly because the best
chinese
researchers in ai end up working in the
united states and often stay
and ultimately become citizens so i
think this is a technological contest
i think cold war ii will be much more uh
a race
uh in technology than cold war one was
of course there was a
a tech race a space race uh in in cold
war one and i think there will be in
cold war too and a cyber space
race and right now the u.s leads in i
think
most of the key domains but it will not
continue to lead unless it really does
maintain that level of investment in
research and development and
competition which is really the key to
producing the best results
uh and so we mustn't make the mistake of
thinking that the way to compete with
china
is through economic planning and by my
account we now have three plans coming
from the biden administration
uh in the form of major legislation huge
amounts of expenditure
total bill of around six trillion
dollars and i look at that and i ask are
we about to repeat the mistakes
of the 1960s and 70s when it seemed as
if
the only way to compete with the soviet
union was to do economic planning
the way they did that turned out to be a
completely
wrong conclusion and the way the united
states won the cold war was in fact with
with a free market economic model under
ronald reagan uh not with the kind of
thing john kenneth braith was arguing
for in the 1960s
well actually i'm intrigued that you
brought up chinese researchers and
scientists in ai for example
as you know in in america and in the
west in general there's been a greater
suspicion of chinese
nationals or ethnic chinese working
in stem stem areas where do you think
what do you what role do you think they
play in this sort of future competition
between the two great powers or should
they be
welcomed uh into the west or do you
think that we should be
careful being careful about what they
can take back to china
well this is a huge issue in a way that
it wasn't in cold war one there were
relatively few
soviet citizens in the united states at
any point
uh in the cold war that were in the
later part of the cold war exchanges but
they were on a tiny scale compared with
the really huge amount
of exchange that there is between china
and the us
hundreds of thousands of chinese
students until recently at american
universities and often studying
stem subjects a really significant
number of graduate students working in
in key areas such as artificial
intelligence or quantum computing
and it's true to say uh and this is
something that that we know from
uh from the fbi that there has been
espionage as a consequence
we know that the chinese government uses
all kinds of means to try
to hack western technology
breakthroughs often through cyber means
but also through
human intelligence and this creates an
enormous
problem because of course if if one
chinese national working at one big tech
company turns out to be a spy
then suspicion falls uh on the others
and unfortunately that can include
uh american citizens uh often
uh people from chinese of chinese
heritage you've lived in the united
states for
many years so i do think we have to
remember that
one of the bleaker features of american
history in the 20th century was the way
in which
hostility grew towards uh
german americans uh in world war one and
world war ii and of course
in world war ii towards japanese
americans who were treated shamefully
we mustn't repeat that that history and
i i do see dangers
of that a few years ago more than a
decade ago i used the word chimerica to
describe that period of
symbiotic interaction between the us and
china well there are many chimericans uh
and some of them are good friends of
mine these are people who may have been
born in china
but have worked for many years in the
united states and have become american
citizens
when i became an american citizen by far
the largest group
alongside me in an oakland auditorium
where in fact people born in china and
so
we can't cast aspersions on the
commitment
of chinese americans to the country
they've sworn allegiance to if we start
doing that
we're going to be back in the in the
battle days of uh of the 1940s
uh and i of course i'm very conscious
that i'm talking
uh to someone whose surname is is you
and may uh be encountering
uh in the uk some of the kind of uh
anti-asian prejudice that one reads
about
on both sides of the atlantic that can't
be the way this plays out
it is the chinese communist party that
we are concerned
to combat uh in cold water we do not
want the ccp to become more powerful in
the world than it already is
that is quite different from uh
expressing antagonism
to people of of chinese ethnic origin
neil ferguson thank you so much for
joining spectator tv and you can read
neil ferguson's new book
doom the politics of catastrophe which
is out now
if you enjoyed that conversation you
might also enjoy my podcast series
chinese whispers where i look into
chinese politics society and its history
a link should be up on the screen now
[Music]
you